for six years we've seen this photograph
now for the first time we've heard from
both their lawyers
prince andrew's legal team telling the
judge in new york the abuse allegations
are baseless non-viable and potentially
unlawful those acting for virginia du
frey insisting their case against him
has been effectively served after she
claimed she was sexually abused by him
three
lisa
times
represents some of jeffrey epstein's
victims and says the judge has a number
of ways he could speed up the process
in many cases where i'm trying to serve
a high profile person and i do a lot of
these cases the judge will give us an
alternative so that people can't just
continue to hide behind gates and walls
and fly out of the country
and i think those alternatives are
available in the uk as well a document
filed just hours before the telephone
court hearing confirmed prince andrews
team would be challenging how the papers
were served
andrew brettler who's represented
hollywood stars on rape allegations told
the judge they have already referred it
to the high court in london and said
their case partly hangs on another
private settlement made by virginia du
frey that they believe protects the duke
and others from any compensation claims
lawyer alan dershowitz is another of
those individuals
the release was cited in the dismissal
of the case against me it precludes
anybody who was covered by the release
from being sued by virginia guffrey
virginia got her money she's gotten over
five million dollars she's built a
beautiful home and in exchange for the
money
that she has received she signed a
release she's bound by that
release duprey's team whose private
investigators served papers here at the
prince's home in windsor have now been
given a week to make any more requests
or apply to the court to help
it's believed that prince andrew is
still in scotland where the queen is
also spending her summer break his
lawyers planning their next steps with
the clock ticking and a judge now
expecting answers
rhiannon mills sky news in windsor